في غفله من الجميع وخصوصا الامريكيين
الصين تسيطر على سوق السيارات اقتربت
السين كثيرا من ان تصبح الثانيه اكبر مصدر
للسيارات في العالم بعد اليابان مباشره
تحول تاريخيا في عالم السيارات حدث خلال
سنتين فقط فقد تضاعف صادرات السيارات
المصنوعه في الصين ثلاث مرات منذ عام 2020
لتصل الى اكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون
سياره العمل الماضي لتتفوق على الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه وتصبح على بعد
60,000 سياره فقط عن المانيا التي تراجعت
صديقتها في السنوات الاخيره بحسب بيانات
نشرتها وكاله
الصينيه باتت متصدره في عديد من اسواق
الشرق الاوسط وامريكا اللاتينيه اما في
اوروبا في المبيعات في الموصل حاليا من
ضمنها سيارات وتسلى مصنوعه في شنغهاي وحتى
سيارات بي ام دبليو
انتاجها حصريا ومن هناك يتم تصديرها الى
اوروبا
الصين تهدفوا لبيعي ثمانيه ملايين سياره
عالميه بحلول عام 2030 هاي اكثر من ضعفي
صادرات السيارات اليابانيه في 20 22
التحول في سوق السيارات حدث على غفله من
الجميع وخصوصا الامريكيين ربما انه حدث
اثناء الجائحه فايروس كرونه او لان
الشركات السيارات الصينيه وركزوا على
اسواق اوروبا واسيا وامريكا اللاتينيه
اكثر من السوق الامريكي الصادرات الصينيه
الى الاتحاد
156 في المئه في عام 20 21 الى 405
و30,000 وحده وفقا للعروسه لكن الارتفاع
السريع في تصدير السيارات الكهربائيه من
الصين قد يولد فعلا قويه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي فيما يتعلق بحمايه التجاره
العامل الاقوى لنمو مبيعات الشركات
الصينيه والسعر فمتوسط سعر سياره صينيه
13,700 دولار اين نحوي الثلثي سعر سياره
المانيه في عام 20 واحد و20 واقل بنحوي
30% من السياره ما يشكل تهديدا للطرازات
اليابانيه والكوريات الجنوبيه الارخص ثمن
اكثر من السيارات الالمانيه التوجه
العالمي لخفض بعثات الكربون دفع بكين الى
تحفيز صانع السيارات الكهربائيه
والمشتريين حيث ان سلسله التوريد المحليه
جعلت صنع السياره الكهربائيه في الصين
ارخص من اي مكان اخر مصنع تسلا في شنغهاي
انتاجه نحو 701 10,000 سياره العمل الماضي
حيث 52% من انتاج الشركه على المستوى
العالمي بي واي دي اكبر منتج للسيارات
الكهربائيه في الصين تطمح بان تصبح
المركبات الكهربائيه للمشتريين ذوي
الميزانيه المحدوده في العالم هل تتوقع ان
تكون سيارتك التاليه الصينيه